I'll address some of the videos that
you've done go ahead
um and fellas you should probably listen
up never
ever never ever ever ever ever ever
almost like Smoky Friday Chris Tucker
okay tell your girl how much money you
make you want to keep your girl a little
curious unsure I don't know I think
we're doing good but I'm not necessarily
sure exactly we're good I think we're
doing nice things you don't never want
to say I make quarter million dollars or
I make 80 grand a year you don't want to
let them know that exact amount you want
to kind of let their mind wander a
little bit we know this now preach
you've actually addressed this in one of
your [ __ ] most famous videos ever you
talked about this Applebee's situation
never telling a girl how much she makes
you basically said I don't tell my girl
how much she makes a girl just wants to
know are we good we're good we're good
we're good Girls Just Want Financial
stability they want to be taken care of
so
what's your take like do you tell your
girl how much money you make like do you
practice what you preach Mr the thing
that happened is that like this YouTube
thing came very quickly you know
pandemic it it it it it burst like you
were at a hundred thousand then you went
to one million like yo so yeah 200.
shout out to you
like no no lie it is what it is yeah so
she was not used to that but in all
those years were together you know she
was a breadwinner who works in the banks
she was the breadwinner she she wore
something I was I'm the artistic dude uh
so you know Arts don't pay yeah right
and then you remember that people
getting their eyeballs
I'm a hundred percent with you like and
that's what I say and Quebec is a bit
different
there's a lot of uh subsidies and stuff
like that but even then like if you're
doing Arts I would say something to
someone in Quebec do comedy
the comic comedians in Quebec are the
rock stars that you have in the US
comedians in Quebec yes specifically yes
who are the most famous comedians who
would know them give me something yeah
like if you listen to radio in English
uh in Quebec it's gonna be all music in
French comedian stalking TV comedian as
a matter of fact I didn't I chose not to
try out I don't think I would have
gotten caught it but I I chose to not
try out to go to the conservatory which
is a place where you go for theater and
stuff like that and try to be a comedian
in order to act in Quebec imagine that
and it kind of worked
so if you go on my IMDb
you're gonna see all the things anyways
all that to say
um yeah don't don't be
yeah
Arts is not the thing yeah it's not a
thing so basically what Arts not being
the thing and her not used to me making
that much money right then covet
happened and then like everybody around
her is not making doing that good and
all this of me here I'm doing super good
she was like yeah so at some point I had
to show the numbers but I shortened once
like this this is what I made this month
okay we're good stop
it's like okay I'm good so if I can just
kind of encapsulate what you're saying
right now you've been with your girl 23
years dog like what you're 40 years old
this is unheard of okay so you've been
you started from the bottom with your
girl essentially I think you've actually
used those words
um
you she used to be the breadwinner she
works in a bank
okay but now you're probably making more
money than her yeah correct I am no
doubt yeah sorry boo sorry babe she's
not sorry
has the relationship changed the
Dynamics of the reason changed and what
is the role of the man of the woman in
the relationship right now it didn't it
didn't change because when I was doing
less money I was making sure that at
least things were taken care of you know
I mean there's some things that we're
taking care of like oh yeah these things
need to be fixed I got that you need to
change the breaks of your car I'm Gonna
Change I'm hear the brakes guy no I'm
gonna I'm gonna do it manually I'll pop
it in the video I'll go buy the parts I
don't have the money to do that if I
don't have the money I'll I'll still
find a way to make it happen so if I
don't have the money me I'll buy the
parts and I'll work four hours to change
the brakes I know it doesn't take four
hours but for someone who doesn't know
you don't know so I'll do that and
everything and stuff and when I got by
the way I got zero clue how to change
[ __ ] brake pads
yeah
okay so this so okay this doesn't work
in the house let me try to fix it it
wasn't if if I don't win money yeah at
least if you got a problem my point is
to make your life easier okay okay and
you're supposed to make my life easier
too so we we a team on that so okay how
can I make this [ __ ] easier already
making my life easier I need to put my
bag up without a bag
so I do this [ __ ] and then the the
YouTube pops well before the YouTube My
Career was getting there so I was like
okay we're a status quo we're good and
then after that the YouTube happened it
was popping and I was able to just
so but you're saying there's been no
change in the dynamic of the
relationship I find that hard to believe
and I'll tell you why go ahead for 20
you've been together 23 years for 20
years or so she was the breadwinner yeah
over the last three years I'm gonna pop
a little collar right here
I've been preach balling out
Dynamics must have changed a little bit
you must have been like here's some bde
for you little big dick energy like
what's up homie's a millionaire now I
used to be broke as a joke I mean
there's the Dynamics the bde can still
be there
even if you don't have money oh that's a
thing maybe he has a black guy
big
ger
that's just what it is
but that's my water
[Laughter]
it doesn't see the dynamic but it
alleviates the tension of money but the
dynamic is pretty much the same without
the tension of money or the tension of
like we just like we were still moving
smart we when I when I was not making
when we were not making that much money
I was not we were not living in big ass
house we're not living in a big ass
apartment modest I was living in an
apartment block
that my parents home
smart but have you guys upgraded your
life in the last two or three years
but no but okay you want to hear if it
upgraded absolutely yes I'm I'm 40 but
with a mind of a kid so I got toys
why do I have four motorcycles why why
because you probably made more money
than the last four years because I can
okay that's the answer I have a T-Rex
why because I can that's my toys I like
toys right there's little things like
that I bought on eBay recently a this is
not a flame drawer by the boring company
of Elon Musk Elon Musk because I can but
I have a flamethrower because I can't
afford a flame that's it no I've got
four motorcycles because I can afford
four more so if you like that clip click
right here to watch another or if you
want to watch the entire saucecast click
right here
oh